Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I’m
going to explain a science fiction
film called “D0wnsizing.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in Edvardsen Institute,
Norway. A group of scientists are researching
a procedure of some sort. We see Dr.
Jorgen and his colleague, Andreas,
excitedly talk about an experiment that has
been successful. The two hug in excitement.
Cut to five years later. Andreas is presenting
their study to an auditorium full of people in
a Convention centre in Italy. He has a box with
himself that he carefully sits on the podium.
He then gives the audience a speech about
the negative effects of global warming and
scarcity of food and water it causes. He goes
on to explain that their project will not just
reduce global warming, but also solve the
problem of scarcity of natural supplies.
He says that this is the only practical and
humane remedy to mankind’s gravest problem.
He then proceeds to reveal what is inside
the box. The audience gasps when they see
a tiny Dr. Jorgen in the box. He looks like
any normal human being, but smaller in size.
No one can believe their eyes. They stand up to
get a better view of Dr. Jorgen. Dr. Jorgen asks
everyone to take a seat. A tiny microphone stands
in front of him and he starts speaking. He says
that five years ago, he and his team developed
a procedure that reduces all organic material
to cellular level by a ratio of 2744 to 1. Using
this process, Dr. Jorgen had turned miniscule.
The procedure was tested on a
large number of plants and animals,
and they have found out that the procedure is
irreversible, but has no side effects at all.
Thirty six volunteers joined Dr. Jorgen’s team,
and they have been living life as a small person
ever since. The procedure only requires the
removal of dental and other prosthetics.
The person fully recovers after an
hour or two after being turned small.
They then bring out the thirty six volunteers
of the project, who are now small people.
They have lived in the world’s first
small colony for the past four years.
They have also birthed a little baby.
The audience clapped in admiration. This is
the biggest discovery in history. The concept of
downsizing is now introduced. People from around
the world watch the television in shock as they
broadcast attractive advertisements about the
discovery. They encourage everyone to go miniscule
to save the planet and for a better life.
Paul Safranek is one of the viewers. He watches
the advertisement in awe. He goes home to his
sick mother; she is the only person in Paul’s
life. She complains about the downsizing program,
saying that the same energy must be put
into finding the cure of her illness.
It is now ten years later, Paul's mother has
long passed on. Paul now works as an occupational
therapist and is married to his wife, Audrey
Safranek. The couple is struggling financially.
The two have to relocate to a new home
because of their financial problems.
Meanwhile, the downsizing program has become
more and more popular through the years.
Several miniscule colonies have been
established throughout the world.
3% of the world has gone through downsizing
and currently lives in those colonies.
One day, the Safraneks go to their highschool
reunion. There, they meet their old friends, Dave
and Carol Johnson, who have downsized. After the
reunion, they gather at a friend’s house where The
Johnsons boast about it being the best decision
they have ever made in their life. They now live
in a miniscule colony in New Mexico called the
Leisureland. When Paul praises Dave for doing
so much for the environment, Dave reveals that
he only did it for the money. After downsizing,
expenses drop by 90%. Dave used to be broke in
Vegas, before they decided to downsize. Now,
the two are going on a six months trip to Italy
and living their best life in a huge mansion.
Interested in the miniature life, the
following day, Paul and Audrey go to
a Leisureland convention. There, a downsized man
explains to them the benefits of being downsized.
He shows them the house of his dreams right
in front of him. The miniature house opens
to reveal a luxurious interior. A woman is inside
the house who boasts about her diamond jewellery
that cost her only eighty three dollars. Paul
and Audrey are fascinated by the luxurious life
of the miniatures. They then go to a viewing
area, where they look over the Leisureland.
The colony is covered with nets to keep
away mosquitos and harmful UV rays.
The couple watch in awe and decide
that they too will downsize.
They meet an agent who tells them that in
Leisureland, their 152 thousand dollars is
12 million dollars to live on. Paul and Audrey
are stunned. Later, we see them selling their
belongings in a yard sale, so that they can sell
everything and live as miniatures. Later that day,
they meet at a pub where their friends and
family wish them goodbye. Later that night,
the two keep their rings in a box to be brought
to their miniature house when they relocate.
The following day, they drive to the Leisureland
convention where they will undergo downsizing.
However, Audrey seems to be
doubtful of the decision.
The two are separated in the waiting room. Paul
is taken for the procedure before Audrey. They are
told that they will meet after the procedure, when
they are already downsized. At the beginning of
the procedure, they shave Paul’s head and eyebrows
off as those cannot be downsized. Then they change
him into hospital gowns, and sedate him to trim
all the hair on his body. They do the same to
several other men beside Paul. Since downsizing
cannot be performed with dental prosthetics,
they perform a dental surgery on everyone and
remove the prosthetic teeths. They are then
taken to the incubation hall where the downsizers
are kept naked. The doors to the hall close.
After some time, it opens and we see
everyone inside has been downsized.
Now, they are scooped up gently with a spatula
and put into miniature beds. Then, they are handed
down to small nurses from the Leisureland. Their
dental prosthetics are put back into their cavity.
Finally, the procedure is done and the
newly downsized people are sent to rest.
When Paul wakes up, he is alone in the waiting
room. A nurse greets him. She also gives him
a huge cracker as a gift. He asks for Audrey’s
whereabouts, so the nurse goes to look for her.
She comes in with a phone some time
later. Audrey speaks from the other end.
She frantically tells Paul that they shaved
her head and eyebrows. Then we see a bald
Audrey with only one eyebrow at the airport.
Paul is shocked as it turns out that Audrey ran
away as they started shaving her eyebrows; she has
decided to not downsize at the very last moment.
The two yell at each other through the phone.
Paul is now alone in the new city of miniatures.
He is guided to his luxury mansion but
he now has to live there alone.
It is now a year later. Paul has divorced
Audrey and settled into a new apartment.
He had anticipated an easy life but the divorce
settlement took away half of his assets.
He currently works in a call centre and is dating
a girl named Kristen. One night, they are in
Paul’s room having dinner when Paul’s upstairs
neighbor, Dusan, comes in to inform him that he
is holding a party. Later, Kristen and Paul break
up, prompting him to attend Dusan’s party.
Paul has the time of his life. He kisses
a random girl and accepts a pill from her.
The drug starts to take Paul over,
and he enjoys himself the whole night.
The following morning, he wakes up under a table
at Dusan’s apartment. The cleaning workers arrive.
One of the workers who limps, catches Paul’s
eyes since he is an occupational therapist.
He asks her to sit down ,and helps her with her
prosthetic legs. Paul recognizes the worker as
Ngoc Lan Tran, a Vietnamese political activist
who was jailed and downsized against her will.
Ngoc Lan’s story was broadcasted worldwide
then, but eventually it died down.
Ngoc Lan takes Paul to her neighborhood to
check on people there, even though he is a
physical therapist and not a doctor. Paul sees
that the place she lives is in extreme poverty,
even though they are miniatures. There, Paul helps
Ngoc Lan with her prosthetic leg but accidentally
breaks it. As a result of his screw-up, Ngoc
Lan makes him do her cleaning job until her
new prosthetic legs arrive. Paul goes to work with
Ngoc Lan everyday and does the cleaning for her.
They collect the leftover food from the people
they work for, and bring it back to Ngoc Lan’s
community to distribute it between the poors.
Paul sees the good in Ngoc Lan. Even though she
is suffering herself, she doesn’t forget
to help other people in her community.
One day, Ngoc Lan gets a cleaning job at
Dusan’s. Dusan is surprised to see Paul
working as a cleaner, and makes fun of
him. Paul informs him that he has to do
this for next six weeks to a month. Seeing his
friend suffer, Dusan decides to help him.
He offers Paul a chance to get away by joining him
and his friend, Joris Konrad, in going to Norway,
where the first small community was created.
However, Ngoc Lan insists that she wants to go
too, because she was called by the Doctor who
started this all, Dr. Jorgen. The doctor too
lives in the same colony, and wanted to meet Ngoc
Lan because of her heroic protests in Vietnam.
The boys almost do not believe her,
but they eventually leave for Norway.
Cut to a few days later, all of them are
travelling in a fjord in Dusan's yacht.
They suddenly encounter Dr. Jorgen and his wife
in their own yacht going to the colony as well.
Ngoc Lan finally meets Dr. Jorgen, who apologizes
to her because his procedure was used wrongfully
on her. There, the group is informed about the
methane release in Antarctica that will increase
global warming by a vast percentage. This cannot
be stopped, and because of mass overpopulation,
the human race will eventually become extinct
in one hundred years. The downsizing was made to
reduce the possibility to some extent, but only
3% of the whole world is downsized. Dr. Jorgen
is devastated that his creation was too late to
save the world. The damage is irreversible.
Later, Ngoc Lan and Paul are together in her
cabin. Paul checks her legs. One thing leads
to another, and they end up having sex.
The following morning, they finally reach the
first colony. It is a tiny village where people
live in harmony. They are welcomed wholeheartedly.
There, the villagers have created a large vault
inside a mountain to insulate the colony and
preserve humanity in the event of an extinction.
The whole village, along with Dr. Jorgen and his
wife, plan to go inside the vault the following
day. Inspired by Dr. Jorgen’s words, Paul too
wants to go with the colony. He feels as though he
was brought there for a reason. So, when Ngoc asks
him to come back with her, he denies. Dusan and
Joris too are returning back to their home.
It is now the following day; a few hours
before everyone migrates to the vault.
Ngoc asks Paul if he had sex with her because
he pities her. Paul replies that he really
cares about her, but the vault gives his
life a purpose. The time finally comes;
Paul says his farewell and goes into the
vault while the other three stand outside.
However, Paul changes his mind midway, he
likes Ngoc too much to leave for the vault.
He comes back and hugs her. Soon,
the vault’s door closes forever.
The four of them return to Leisureland.
Back there, Ngoc and Paul live their
lives together while helping the people
of Ngoc’s community, living in slums.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like
to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.